who are some of your peers that you're
uh like fans of musically because
there's a lot of dope dope dope artists
right now especially that do the melodic
shape
uh like i really mess with all of them
like i i tell
them you know when i'm driving i listen
to all that music like you know i'm
saying
i messed with broadway like i knew
broadway when his come up like you know
what i'm saying no he's been bubbling at
it i mean he's been doing this thing for
for some years too i feel like you guys
i feel like he was born well that's
crazy
why like if you go look at his uh hard
on ice video like
i was in like that was when he was out
there like man do a drop do a drop flip
i'm like yeah
i messed with him like he was i think he
was opening up for me in a show in
florida
and then after that like i think he i
don't know if he redid the deal with
alamo or what but after that he just
started going crazy you know
yeah he's dope man he's fire i think
like uh
i mean we talked about clever clever is
really yeah incredible
have you have you i like pardoning it i
like part of this dodo that's probably
my favorite or
he's one of the hardest writers ever
yeah have you heard blast from l.a
um you know one of my one of my uh
one of my female friends uh
she just interviewed him uh i don't
think you know tally tally spencer
okay yeah yeah she just interviewed him
so that's that's how i heard him then i
started getting to
he's fired no i just think it's still
man i just think that like you know
it's it's it's a good place where music
is
because you know three four years ago it
was like that over modulated soundcloud
[ __ ]
yeah like it was just a lot of like it
just like music
wasn't and that's crazy is that you were
making like melodic dope [ __ ] when that
wasn't even the wave
yeah and the sound just came to you yeah
so that shit's dope man